MALE SPEAKER: Developing
apps for Android
is an exciting opportunity
to change the world.
I'm going to step you through
the process of getting started
with Android using Android
Studio, while also sharing
some pro tips based on the
experiences of a real Android
start-up.
Before we even install
Android Studio,
you should start thinking about
the app you plan to build.
Start by looking
at the challenges
you, your friends,
or family face.
Could you build an app to
solve one of those problems.
Let's take a look
at our start-up
and see where their
idea came from.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-There's somebody in
there. [INAUDIBLE] Open up.
[DOOR KNOCKING] [INAUDIBLE]
-Hurry.
Get it open.
-Get something in there.
-Just kick it open.
Come on.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[DOOR CRASHES]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Well that was unexpected.
-What the hell was that?
What's going on?
-Zombies.
Obviously those were zombies.
I don't know how but, I bet the
bald guy is somehow to blame.
-Oh sure.
Solve one problem with the
Android [? D'nomicon ?]
and suddenly this is my fault.
-How are we going to
survive a zombie apocalypse?
We don't have any training.
It's not like we can
go to Google Play
and download an App.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
MALE SPEAKER: Like
our start-up team,
you have a problem to solve.
So it's time to
start developing.
First, check that you have
version 7 or later of the Java
Development Kit installed.
Open a terminal window or a
command prompt and type Java
dash version.
I'm doing this on a Mac but
it should look very similar
on Linux or Windows.
The Java version number
is showing after the one.
So here you can see.
I've got JDK
version 8 installed.
If you see an error or the
version is less than 7,
you'll need to download
and install the JDK.
From this download page, find
the Java platform Standard
Edition.
Select download and then
select the right bundle
for your operating system.
I'm on a Mac so I'll accept
the license agreement
and download the Mac OSX x64
installer from the Java SE
development kit.
Once that's downloaded,
locate the file
and double click it to begin
the installation process.
Once that's completed,
go back to your terminal
and confirm that it's
installed correctly.
Now you're ready
install Android Studio.
We'll start by navigating to
the Android Studio home page
on developer.android.com/sdk.
There's a big button
at the top that
says download Android Studio.
Click that.
Now carefully read the
terms and conditions.
Select the check box confirming
that you've read them
and agree with them.
And then press the download
Android Studio button
to begin the transfer.
It's a pretty big
file, so while you're
waiting for that
to complete, you've
got a great opportunity to
start thinking about the APIs
you'll be using to build an
app that solves your problem.
This early in the
product life cycle
it's worth exploring some of
the options made possible using
new versions or even
early access beta versions
of the Android platform.
Here we're looking
at the new APIs
available from the Marshmallow
release of Android.
Let's take a look at our
start-up team exploring
possibilities for their app.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Ian.
What's our status?
How are we doing?
-Well I'm sure glad we
got this Duel Booted
Chromebook on the way out.
Google's got APIs for location
based services and mapping.
-What about a fitness API.
And we should make sure it
works with Android Wear.
-Hey.
Hey.
Focus.
Zombies.
Is there like a zombie
killing or zombie protection
API or something?
-Well location apps are
pretty hot right now.
-I'm not finding
anything in here.
-Check the Android
Zed preview release.
-The what?
-The Android Zed.
The preview.
-What?
-Zee.
Zee.
Like zee as in zebra.
-Oh.
Australians.
-Americans.
-Oh, yeah.
Here it is.
There's even a method is user
a zombie in the framework now.
That would've been nice to
have in the support library.
[END PLAYBACK]
MALE SPEAKER: Now that
your download is finished,
you're ready to
install Android Studio.
If you're on a Mac
like me, double
click the file to open it.
Then drag the Android
icon into applications.
Now double click the icon
to start Android Studio
for the first time.
If you're on Windows,
double clicking the download
will launch an installation
similar to what
I'm about to show
you here for the Mac.
We'll then select a
standard installation
for Android Studio.
Hit finish to complete
the installation.
That's going to
start downloading two
to three gigs, which
includes the Android SDK.
That's going to take awhile so
it's the perfect opportunity
to take a break,
make a cup of tea,
and think about things like
how to monetize your app.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-What do you think we should
do about monetization?
Because I feel
like in-app billing
would be great for all the
extra skills and defenses
but subscription would
be so consistent.
-Maybe we could try A/B
testing both of them.
See which one turns out
to be more effective.
-That's true.
That's a good idea.
-Hey.
Should we worry about
performance this early?
I mean if you're being
chased by a zombie,
it seems like we'd
want to be responsive.
Right?
-Right.
So, clearly, we can't
use any eNoms in our app.
-I don't know.
Is that risking
premature optimization?
-Hey now, listen
here, we've talked--
-All right.
[RECORD SCRATCHING]
-Download's done.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
The download is complete.
So hit Finish and your
installation is done.
Now you're ready
to start coding.
We'll start by creating
a new Hello World project
that you can build from.
Now, keep in mind that
Android Studio is constantly
being updated and improved.
As a result, the process
for your particular version
may look a little different
to what I'm showing on screen.
Don't be alarmed.
The options presented
in the general flow
should still be very similar.
Start by choosing to start a
new Android Studio project.
Give it a name and
enter a domain.
These two will be used together
to form your app's package
name.
Package names must be unique.
So, ideally, you'll own a
domain and you can use it here.
Even if you don't,
try and select
something that's unlikely to
collide with another developer.
I happen to own a domain
so I'll enter that here.
I'm happy to use the
default project location.
So let's hit Next to continue.
Now we can select the devices
we plan to target with our app.
Eventually we'll
want to make our app
available on all
possible form factors.
But for our first
ever application,
let's keep it simple and
target only phones and tablets.
Next we can choose the minimum
SDK we plan to support.
Selecting a min SDK lets
you choose your app's level
of backwards compatibility.
A lower value will make your
app available to a larger
number of devices.
But in turn, will require
you to do more work
to ensure compatibility
with devices
that may not support all the
features added in newer Android
releases.
You can check to see what
proportion of Android devices
are running on each
platform release
by clicking this
help me choose link.
When we filmed this
video in October of 2015,
supporting back to Android
4.0 or Ice Cream Sandwich,
let us reach around
90% of devices.
Now you're prompted to select a
new activity or user interface
screen type to add
to your project.
To get started, we'll
choose a blank activity.
Give it a name and a title.
The other files, layout,
and menu resources
will be automatically
generated for you.
And you can keep
the default names.
Then hit Finish.
Read some tips and wait for
your new project to be created.
This may take a little while
the very first time you run it.
So here's one we
prepared earlier.
Your Hello World app
is now ready to run.
You can see it running
on the emulator
by hitting the green
Run button like this
and selecting the emulator.
But it's much more fun to run
it on a real Android device.
Enable USB debugging by
navigating to the Settings
and going down to About Phone.
Then scroll down and press
the build number seven times.
This will enable
developer options.
Navigate back.
Select Developer
options and enable US
bugging from within there.
If you're running
Windows, you'll
also need to download a
driver for your phone.
You can find drivers and
installation instructions
for them here on the
Android developer site
at developer.androi
d.com/tools/extra/oem-usb.
Now plug your phone into your
computer and if prompted,
choose to allow USB debugging.
Hit the Run button in
Android Studio but this time,
select your real device.
Congratulations.
You are running your
first app on a real phone.
With that, you're ready to
start building a real app.
Unlike this example,
you need to spend
a lot of time working on a
delightful, responsive, and
intuitive user experience.
Speaking of which, let's see
how our start-up is getting on.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-So I've got the
app running but,
how do I know if it's working?
-It's not working.
-Have you enabled real time
location in the settings?
-Wait, is that the brain
icon or the celery stick?
-Celery stick.
Then you scroll to the bottom
and hit the version number
seven times.
-Joanna, are you
getting any of this?
-Hmm.
Oh.
I'm sorry.
I meant to tell you guys.
I decided to join a different
start-up called Meatr, which
will connect zombies
with host humans
and make sure that they're
fresh juicy brains on demand.
So it's going to be great.
But I guess I
should probably go.
Good luck, you guys.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-She could have left the shovel.
[END PLAYBACK]
MALE SPEAKER: Unfortunately,
for our courageous start-up,
they were late to market.
And they had some serious
issues with their UX design.
You can avoid mistakes
using our resources
to learn how to build and
design great Android apps.
Good luck.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Meatr delivery.
-Hey.
Oh.
-Hi you guys.
-How are you doing?
You know, Colt, we
definitely used an eNom
to get to market faster.
[YELLING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]